hello and welcome to this video River
Boca I see a point did that plain before
I think I played him before yeah with
the in the scotch four nights am i right
with that I can't look it up actually
let me check it yeah that was the last
white game so he needs some sort of
improvement I mean not that this opening
was terrible or anything but I had a
convenient position for sure
yeah let's see what he does the game
before he played c6 which is very normal
of course yeah b8 I think we are
following that game Queen to c7 before
something like that but what happened
don't exactly remember the move water
uh-huh okay well that's possible of
course you can still do you want c4 I
can just take with them with the bishop
in those situation where black pushes c5
a good way to regroup is actually to
play the bishop to f3 in this kind of
this kind of structure well okay I mean
here I can also just take similarly to
the game before you know it's actually
there's more than one good movie em all
so p1 is good what am I doing here
they don't like CC Fair who rupee one
looks a bit odd after having played
rugby one before but still
[Music]
in a situation after c4d 496 context I
would like to prevent him from playing E
5 I wonder if I should just double me
this is a move but c4 hmm a black C form
hmm a bit bit unsure how I should play
this Queen g3 has had an idea it isn't
really threatened much look III it's
uncommon but maybe trying to double on
DD file and d4 it's not an issue at all
and c4 yeah c4 I just go back to have
one that doesn't make more sense I think
well it took me a bit long that said
could be a thing could be an issue
okay yeah well here it is a checksum
okay if I go rookie one he can't go we
five maybe you maybe I'm not really
doing this correctly and he can push all
those pawns to his to his benefit
oh I just completely overlooked that
after he five I wanted to go Queen to f5
he has got Luke f4 which is quite
awkward when I can go to g5 aged six
Queen to six okay maybe it's not too bad
this I'm not sure about rookie five I
mean this can be good for black it's
possible that it can also be loosening
quite a bit
yeah I'm not sure c3 he cannot push
because I can take it
yeah taking us never really a good idea
for him I wonder if Rukh t1 is ever good
provoking d3 first of all I had to play
some quick moves to knock it was on time
I'd like to get a bit yeah catch up a
little bit is what I was trying to say
okay
[Music]
and then it's got to get fun okay I take
it doesn't doesn't really matter I mean
that's what I'm saying is it's okay
anyway because that ending is some is
okay for me and your home shouldn't just
blunder stuff that could happen of
course I'm not doing that I should be
fine yeah blundering stuff that's the
same as shoot I mean it's just words of
course with the night against the bishop
at the very beginning of this ending and
I'm blundering this my ya know you're
winning of course with the bloody nitric
check yeah at the beginning this is just
a bad ending I mean this is just a bad
ending for black okay the engine gives
it equal but should be totally repair
here doesn't matter that he's got to
pass on the default does the engine give
equal that's surprising why am I not
better here I mean I understand that his
King is stronger which still came they
just really they have got some
weaknesses but I mean occasion ever lose
losing is really bad okay so let's have
a look through this ya mean I came
multiple things after I took too much
time that's one thing
okay ninety-five and he gives up okay
yeah
sometimes good to be at least not a
technical idiot and oh yeah it was it
was easy now his background is just
terrible and just take him and that just
Vince Fletcher he's got a terrible
structure losing the most important one
okay after that and surprisingly I'm
also better hood okay this this wasn't
just wasn't clear to me but I really
felt I was I was doing okay it was of
course a bit I was doing this in a very
ambitious way but really I should never
lose this bloody position that's really
bad really bad Keeney five he's got to
get this 94 so what do I have to do king
detune and he I mean sorry but your
black has to be cautious if I get this
coordinated a three before I'm just
playing for win for nothing hmm my
usually a night is just absolutely
terrible and such an ending unless you
allow the point to promote but I didn't
play well I mean this is this is this
was of course extremely easy even here
this is quite good but I didn't
I should do this that looks a lot more
logical getting this just attacked and
he doesn't really have a good move
available look f-4b should be 5 so
awkward now he's not well played at all
by me
yeah thanks a lot for watching